let's read that first story from the
hill
russia threatens military and political
consequences if finland or sweden tries
joining nato
russian's foreign minister ministry
spokesperson maria zakharova warned
against other countries attempting to
join nato after russia started a war
with ukraine thursday finland and sweden
should not base their security on
damaging the security of other countries
and their
ascension accession to nato can have
detrimental consequences and face some
military and political consequences
zacharova said in a viral clip of a
press conference the ministry later
posted the same threat on its twitter
finland and sweden have given
significant military and humanitarian
support to ukraine since russia invaded
one pretext russia has given for
attacking ukraine is that nato would not
give any assurances that ukraine would
not be allowed to join the
intergovernmental military alliance see
i i'm gonna i'm gonna pause real quick
and say a few things
it's hard to believe any of the stuff
that's coming out you know i mean this
stuff is on twitter these videos and
these statements but a lot of the videos
a lot of the claims a lot of the
propaganda just seems that it seems like
attempts to manipulate the public it's
hard to know what's true
but we have had stories coming up for
quite some time this is from france 24
the russians are coming sweden on edge
as russia flexes military muscle it
could be
a long-standing propaganda campaign
i just don't really think so i think
russia has literally invaded russia has
said that they're engaged in a military
operation call it whatever you want i
think the reality is vladimir putin
feels like he lost he lost the influence
battle the u.s basically bought ukraine
he couldn't do it so here we are getting
into war the question is this threat
towards sweden and finland is it
legitimate or is putin just spiraling
out of control nick i'm wondering what
your thoughts are i don't you know i
don't see putin's never struck me as the
sort of guy that like just spirals out
of control
right the sort of guy that gets pissed
off and just starts you know
executing generals and and things like
that he's always seemed to be again i
don't think he's a good guy he's a bad
dude but i've also thought he was a
fairly calculating guy i mean the guy
has managed to stay in power this long
within russia uh within an environment
where it's it's fairly unstable from a
political perspective with a bunch of
oligarchs running around um so i don't
know i i don't i don't
i'm not convinced that he's at a point
where he's just kind of lost his mind
i think he's he's pushing to see how far
he can get away with what he's doing
um i i think he knows he's got a a
fairly short time to be able to act in
order to consolidate gains and then it's
all a question of what are you bringing
right when it shows up when inevitably
we get to the negotiating table what
does that look like and what do you
transform in order to get what you want
so i don't i don't really understand why
you bring sweden and finland into this
um but
again
it's
what do you see what is being an
unstable guy what are your thoughts on i
mean you were talking about
unconventional warfare is that is that
that's where you specialized in when
you're in the military yeah so what are
your thoughts on everything we're seeing
right
just to preface this
none of us uh here at least thought
putin would go this far with ukraine
yeah and so this seems very much like
conventional warfare
but yeah and it seems like they're
saying uh while kiev has some major
gains they've taken down a lot of
russians russia's assets they're going
to lose and then there's questions about
what they can do in the insurgency phase
in the resistance phase i don't look
everyone likes to talk about the fact
that russia's not the power of the
soviet union was that's absolutely true
right it's got a gdp that's a little bit
bigger than mexico's right it's got a
population of about you know 150 million
um so not what the soviet union was but
when we talk about russia doesn't have
the gdp to fight a sustained war yeah
you know who also doesn't ukraine
so this this isn't about them having to
fight a war for years this is about how
quickly can they get their gains
consolidate those gains and then put
themselves in a good position on the
negotiating table and so from ukraine's
perspective they had to know that you're
not going to go toe-to-toe especially
with the geography of ukraine it's not
like you can go fighting in the
mountains for 10 years like they did in
afghanistan right right it is built for
take warfare and the russians know a
little something about tank warfare um
especially in ukraine right there's a
lot of historical battles there but what
a lot of people don't understand about
this is
immediately fought in world war ii the
ukrainians fought like a 10-year
insurgency against the soviets
so there is a history of them fighting
over that area the borders of ukraine
are a little bit weird from an ethnical
stand from an ethnic standpoint so at
this point this is a question of using
the natural geography that you have
right around the dynaper and whatnot in
order to slow like the major advance and
then it's largely going to be urban
battles if you can be in an urban
environment and you can make them pay
because that's where asymmetric warfare
works really well for the defender for
the person that doesn't have the the
technology
but if you're sitting in a city right
now and you've got an at4 and rpg or or
if you've got really something good like
the us gave them like javelins
okay you got a you know you got a 10 000
or a 15 000 rocket that's taking out a
you know 15 20 million dollar tank right
that that adds up
and so if they fight the insurgency
point in the urban areas which are kind
of behind the lines of the russian
advance and then they use their military
in order to kind of stop them at some of
these main geographical areas rivers
being one of the best
they can drag this out and they can make
russia pay a much higher price for it
and that's what i don't think russia can
afford i want to pull up this uh this
google map real quick of the you know
eastern european region you have moscow
you got russia you've got ukraine here
you can see it
when vladimir putin says he wants
assurances that ukraine won't be joining
nato i think tulsi gabbard came out and
she was like just give give them
assurances ukraine won't join nato it's
like have y'all looked i'm a fan of
tulsi but have you looked at a map right
yeah estonia and latvia are eu are i'm
sorry our nato members oh yeah they're
already on the border they take it very
seriously and then if you go up and you
look at sweden which you know look
russia's got saint petersburg they've
got kaliningrad in the baltic sea
sweden not nato but now obviously
russia's threatening finland not nato
but also
putin well russia is basically
threatening them they're both in these
same meetings with nato
so when moscow was like oh we don't want
nato on our borders like they've been
there dude no no i mean i i i know
sweden and finland but to act like this
is the the line for him now i i perhaps
it's fair to say he i i'm not saying
he's spying out controls like a madman
but he's desperate yeah you know russia
is not the power it once was and it's
being weakened it's being pressed upon
it's already got nato on its borders and
now it's going to have sweden finland
ukraine
putin he's done his only option
basically is to bend the knee to the
west and say you know how may i serve my
leash and he will he doesn't want to do
that no so he's like i'll go out with a
bang i suppose oh no i think he i think
he is a um i think he's someone that
wants to believe in the greatness of
russia that would love to see the
russian empire once again on a on a
global stage as something that's
respected as opposed to kind of a
second-rate power
um i and again you're growing up he was
once a kgb right officer like this was a
guy that believed in the greatness of
russia regardless of whether or not he
was a communist right and i think he
sees
again the these countries that used to
be in the russian sphere of influence
um he's finding different excuses for
kostas belly in order to justify why
he's going to war
i think some of this too has to do with
internal dynamics within russia i mean
you have a decreasing birth rate you
have you know records showing that
you've got a record number of of you
know kids and teenagers that are
alcoholics
right
look i don't think any of us are shocked
by the fact
that there are plenty of times when
throughout history when a domestic
leader had problems at home a war abroad
was a great way to you know kick-start
your your nation and get them focused on
something you know the the again the
greatness of of whatever it was and look
our nation hasn't been beyond that sort
of enticement in the past
um but so yeah i don't buy that it was
ukraine potentially joining like would
this have happened anyway yeah i don't i
don't think nato was the full crime i
think nato made a convenient excuse for
putin to do something that he already
wanted to do they're trying really hard
to push this this propaganda this
anti-trump propaganda that's it's it's
so man the propaganda is mind-numbing
ugh you know it's under trump putin did
not make these moves no and so the only
real response they have because the
first thing i started seeing from these
activists was
that um oh oh thank heavens trump wasn't
president when this happened because
we'd be worse off and i was like for
four years putin backed off yeah and
they said now they're saying it's
because trump gave them everything they
wanted because he was he was opposed to
nato it's like he got nato to pay them
more to pass more money yeah i mean if
anything he was he was stabilizing it in
a sense
no no this is the part where and i i was
i was the other night i was just kind of
pissed off and i said
you know we're i said i can't remember
how long away for a bunch of european
countries to
you know ask the united states to
intervene in the ukraine only to turn
around six months later from now and
[ __ ] about the united states
intervening in ukraine right because
they're always willing to fight to the
last drop of american blood to sustain
their welfare states right
so this idea that when trump came in and
basically told nato hey look a treaty is
an agreement it's a legal agreement and
you're not living up to your part of it
um that that lit a fire under their ass
and quite frankly they needed it and and
the other thing was is that putin also
understood
that trump didn't draw and look i didn't
there was there was things about trump's
policy i didn't necessarily agree with
but
trump didn't do this thing that like
obama did where it's we're going to draw
a fake line in the sand and then when
you cross it we're going to draw a
different line in the sand
putin expected that if trump said you do
this we're going to do this that he
would do it
and that's that's a big part of when
when foreign leaders
you know cannot calculate what you're
going to do
it actually and you have the ability to
actually make good on your your threats
that's a far different dynamic than joe
biden ripping everyone out of
afghanistan which again i wanted the
troops to come home from afghanistan but
ripping everyone out the way that he did
surrender oh my gosh it's it's
afghanistan seemed like they botched
that on purpose
how you abandoned bagram
it was just mind-numbingly insane i
cannot i'm sorry i know i love to cite
hanlon's razor never a tribute to malice
that which can be explained by
incompetence but in this instance i'm
like there's no way you thought
abandoning our air force base before
evacuating people made sense maybe
because biden's a bureaucrat with no
military i don't think it's any military
experience does he even have any
military knowledge well the company
surrendered and routed our troops but
the guys but the guys advising him
certainly did now i
this is the part where this is the part
where i do think
we've seen this trend within within
politics and some of the rhetoric and
and the direction the left is going and
i'm not talking about everyone that
might be a democrat right or a liberal
i'm talking about the hardcore
progressive left
they honestly believe some of this crap
where it's like oh we're just going to
pull everybody out
by september 11th in 2021 and that's
going to be that's going to be our
market it's going to show that we're
dedicated to peace i honestly think
biden is someone that is making a
political calculation based off of photo
ops
and
honestly had no idea it was going to go
this badly even though again to your
point anybody should have been able to
look at that but like you cannot pull
out this way but putin is watching
things like that thanks for checking out
this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there is a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8 pm we'll see you all there